how does be fluid as water work in your
acting career and and when producing
films because you'd said earlier that it
is a roller coaster ride you know
glorious highs and then sometimes lower
lows so how does fluidity come into play
fluidity has to come into play how else
can I go forward you know at every point
when there is a low if I stagnate it's
done for right I mean how do I not flow
forward if I want to go forward in the
creative field I have to I have to allow
the laws are always there the lows are
there every day there are difficulties
every single day challenges every day
but i can only momentarily dwell on the
the negativity part of the challenge it
will continue to keep affecting me in
the back of my mind but I cannot allow
that to affect my present moment for
example right now as I'm sitting here
there are ten issues in the back of my
head as I'm sure it is for all your
human beings right but if I allow those
ten issues to overwhelm my capacity to
answer what you're asking who is that
loss me I am losing out on the the the
amazing outlet of expression you're
giving me you know and this moment where
I can hopefully connect with thousands
and thousands of people across the world
and express my views is dulled it's
dimmed if I allow that to come forward
so i compartmentalize you know I I say
at this moment this is the most
important thing on the planet for me
nothing else enters my head so I will do
my best right this moment we'll see
after this moment I have to go back to
that anyway right so yeah so that is
that is how I approach it it's not easy
you know definitely it's not easy but
whoever said life is easy
you